do you need a new fob for your nissan or
infinity vehicle or maybe you have a
regular key and need a new one of those
for your nissan or infinity vehicle well
i'm mike i want to show you how you can
use this simple key programming kit
available from tomsky.com to program new
fob or new key for your nissan and
infinity vehicles in only 15 minutes
let's take a look once you've ordered
this simple key programming kit from our
website tomsky.com it'll arrive in the
mail in just a few days
in the box
it comes the user guide for the simple
key programmer there's some important
instructions here like making sure your
vehicle battery is good and charged turn
off your headlights your air
conditioning your heater your radio any
lights that are going to be drawing the
battery you don't want the battery to
drain while you're doing the programming
process
all right there's two steps to
programming your fob any fobs that came
in the box are going to require an
activation step
many times if you order additional fobs
that come separately they may not
require the activation step so let me
first show you how to go through the
activation you find your vehicle this
lookup table today we're doing a nissan
altima 2015
and we have the four button remote with
trunk
so
we need code 42.
the instructions will walk you through
everything you need to do the first step
is to press the top and the bottom
button at the same time
and you'll see a blue light that turns
on solid if you got a blue light like
that you know you need to go through
activation
now if you wait too long before entering
the code it'll time out and you have to
start over so be aware that many times
in this programming process steps are
time sensitive
let's get it ready to activate okay
lights on solid we'll use the top button
to enter the number four we'll use the
second button to enter two
one
two
three
four
one
two
now that we've completed that we push
the bottom button on the fob
for about two seconds till it begins
flashing back the code
okay one two three four pause
one two okay we entered the code four
two so it's been activated
we've entered the code four two
successfully so this is now activated
for 2015 nissan altima
now there's a few things you should be
aware of with this
simple key
programmer first it has a
tamper evidence seal so once you use
this on your vehicle it will pair to the
vin on your vehicle now you can program
up to four keys or four fobs for nissan
and ultimate vehicles with this
programmer so that can be helpful just
know you won't be able to use it on a
different vehicle next
in this programming procedure the
instructions tell us to turn it to dial
position number seven
there we got it on 7.
now with the vehicle turned off the
engine not running come down we've got
to find the obd2 port it's down near the
breaking gas pedal in this case we find
it right there we're going to plug the
programmer in we'll we'll hear it beep
as it plugs in
now there's some instructions that'll
help walk you through these steps hold
to confirm means to press the button for
about two seconds
so we've got our one working key fob uh
notice this is the one with the tile key
finder if you don't have one of those
you might want to pick it up on our
website it'll pair to your smartphone to
help you always know where your keys are
at
in case you lose them at the park or
they're lost in your house
okay let's go through this
it says
hold to confirm here we go
i'm gonna open the door
and close the door
and i'm going to turn the hazard lights
on
press to continue
it warns us do not press the brake
during the programming process
press to continue
it's communicating with the vehicle
press and hold the start button until
the dash lights turn on
so i'm pressing and holding the start
button
dash light is turned on i let go
and we press to continue
it's communicating with the vehicle turn
the ignition off
press to continue
all right press start with the remote
the security light will blink
okay i'm going to press
and release
now the security light's flashing on the
dashboard you see that right there
flashed five times
so
this key is now paired again we're going
to
press to continue
all right turn the ignition off
ignition's off
press to continue
all right do we want to pair another key
why yes yes we do we need to pair the
new one now
so press to continue or you press you
click you click once to end but we need
to hold it down to pair another key so
let's hold it down for a couple seconds
okay pick up the next key we got the
next key
this is the new one we're programming
that we activated
press to continue
press start with the remote the security
light will blink here it is we're going
to watch for the security light to blink
i'm pressing
start but i'm not holding it down
one two three four five sorry it was
blurry there
but you saw the security light blink
we're going to press to continue
turn the ignition off
the ignition is now off
press to continue
pair another key hold the pair press end
we're not doing any more key fobs today
so i'm just going to make a quick click
to end
to exit pairings press press start with
paired remote i'm going to press start
press and release the dashboard lights
all turned on
press to continue
start to turn the ignition off turn the
vehicle off
key registration complete
press to continue
okay unplug the
installer
okay i've moved the key fobs away from
my vehicle i'm gonna try and start it
now
[Music]
and it tells me it can't detect a key
okay i've got my original one let's make
sure it works
okay vehicle turned on just fine
now i've got the new one let's try
starting the vehicle with it
and voila
there we have it
both key fobs lock and unlock the doors
and start the vehicle
after you've completed programming don't
forget to cut the emergency keyblade to
avoid the hassle of finding a car
dealership or locksmith to cut the key
you can order our optional key by photos
key cutting service
if you complete programming and you find
that none of your key fobs are working
don't fare
the frequent last question tells you
what to do
programming nissan key fob starts
by racing all fobs now sometimes it goes
wrong and you find you'll have no
working fobs but take a deep breath and
don't panic there's an easy fix to get
the original key fob working again lets
you know right here that you have to go
through this procedure it depends if you
got stuck at step 13 or step 14. in our
case finish step 14
and so it tells us to hold the original
key
on the start button
for 15 seconds and go through that whole
procedure notice how this light is
flashing when pressed
so that tells us that it's still in
pairing mode release the start button
with the original key and then i'm going
to hold it there for about 15 seconds
and then i'm going to repeat this three
times
now watch for that security light
all right you're going to wait 15
seconds
turned
off notice this key registration
complete this key i'll start the vehicle
again
there we go and we can start over at
step one in the programming process the
trick is getting that security light
to turn on and blink five times
one other item i want to warn about in a
very rare but easy to fix situation
there are some push to start nissan
vehicles that have a fuse titled push
button start
if this fuse had been removed
or was burnt out before programming
begins your vehicle may seem like it
stops working the dashboard lights will
not illuminate
around the push button start there are
some letters the lock acc and on buttons
will not be illuminated to fix this you
simply replace this fuse to get your
original key fob working again and then
you can continue programming
now we also offer a full money back
guarantee so if you try this and it just
doesn't work for your vehicle
simply email help tomsky.com and we'll
provide a full refund when you send
everything back with the original
packaging that's it that's just how easy
it is to use this simple key programming
kit from tomsky.com
to make yourself a new fob for your
nissan and infinity vehicles please
visit our website we've got lots of
different kits available as i said at
the beginning we also have vehicles that
program keys for regular turnkey start
vehicles like this
in addition to these smart fobs finally
don't forget to pick up one of these
tile key finders to help make sure your
keys
can always be found if they get lost now
thanks so much for watching have a great
day